je pense que c'est facile d'avoir ce
genre de discours quand on fait pas
partie des 900 millions de personnes qui
ont faim en fait en ce moment
deuxième point sur la partie impression
rend dans une partie plus philosophique
est intéressant effectivement c'est une
vision libérale pur chimiquement pur que
vous nous que vous nous donnez là après
ça renvoie des pros matic qui sont aussi
la morale qui sont qu'est-ce que deux
sont des communautés la liberté est une
fait partie des devises de république il
ya aussi égalité et il y aussi
fraternité comment derrière vous pouvez
avoir une recette qui fonctionne si vous
en avez une toute petite partie qui sent
mais je dirais pas les foules pendant
que la grande partie de la population
trim justement voit une partie de la
richesse qu'elle crée qui est capté par
les autres quand vous dites la richesse
est créée où il crée elle a été aussi
capté un capter vous en parlait dès lors
autant louis xiv les nobles ont bien
captée puis d'un par l'héritage vous
entretenez c'est différent cela elles
ont été captées par la colonisation ils
ont été captées de bien des façons sur
la planète donc la question c'est
comment on trouve un juste équilibre on
est bien d'accord on va pas dire on va
pas tout prendre aux riches pour donner
aux pauvres
ça sent ça va pas non plus résoudre tous
les problèmes des pauvres mais comment
on fait tenir une société et surtout
comment on voit l'être humain là dedans
et ça c'est vrai que c est lors d'un
discours économique mais ça en vaut je
pense à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond sur qu'est-ce que ce s'écrire
[Musique]